[Musique]
cette maison vous la partagez avec jane
ce n'est plus la maison du célibataire
la maison du solitaire que vous avez été
longtemps c'est d'une maison de famille
une sorte de maison de famille bien
coûter mais c'est pas tellement maison
de famille non plus à cette chambre qui
est devant lui
se peut il changer ça seul le travail
il y avait là une chambre d enfant qui
est complètement différent c'est ce qui
devait être la salle de billard dans ma
première idée de maisons de solitaire au
billard et parti qu'est ce qu'il va
devenir un conte atelier c'est devenu
impossible
j'ai fait des concessions n'ont pas trop
ce qui est étonnant c'est que tout est
en noir les murs sont noirs le plafond
est noir mais ce qui est plus étonnant
encore ses couleurs ce qu'on rentre chez
nous sur notre chez vous on ne seront
pas fondre tout de suite que c'est aussi
noir parce que il ya donc un secret
c'est ce que vous avez trouvé le secret
pour faire disparaître ce noir se noie
cette scène là pour moi de simplement de
la ribère sa rigueur absolue
l'enjeu le combat évidemment par le des
portes blanches et des dallages ocré de
la pierre ndjeng et représente pour vous
ce noir vous avez entendu ce que serge
vient de dire ce que vous aviez de son
avis que partageait le même sentiment
entonnoir c'est quand même une vie c'est
comme la nuit finalement les murs à sa
mise des formes qui est propre et et
mais on a fait défaut les frontières
savait que ce nous il n'y a pas de
frontières on voit pas qu'il est à mur
c'est comme une ville seulement quand on
accroche quelque chose sur le mieux on
voit que ça finit là mais c'est tout
alors pour moi c'est c'est comme une
liberté je pense pas les murs il
n'existe pas dans cette maison c'est une
sorte de tableau dans l'espace oui je
suis très maniaque sur quand j'ai trouvé
la place idéale d'un objet par rapport
aux autres selon les rythmes et que
treize éléments terres de 2 du nombre
d'or et bien et ne doit plus bouger dans
un appartement on retrouve la
personnalité de chacun de ceux qui
l'occupent jane qu'est ce que vous avez
apporté ici qu'est ce qui vous
représente ici c'est son univers lui
moi j'ai maison à londres c'est à moi
mais ici c'est à lui mais je sais moi
j'aime beaucoup vivent dans une
atmosphère de la tête de quelqu'un
d'autre et j'apporte les choses il est
happé sui lola des choses comme ça qui
qui allait dans son monde à lui
ça m'excite autant que si c'était si
c'était mon invention mais lui l'a
toujours vu lui et laura et moi j'ai
tout cela mignon il est le seul noir que
je supporte les gentils killing me campi
xporter gentil là maintenant je peux
faire que c'est moi qui achetaient
comment est votre maison à long canon
c'est une bombe
parce que c'est toujours des enfants qui
détruisent tout et j'ai des choses j'ai
débattu voir tout en rouge c'est pas
c'est pas une finesse exclusive désert
mais ça ça explique que je suis toujours
désordre
j'ai mes shoes par tout ce que je
n'admets pas essayer ici j'ai jamais je
suis très rigoureux et enfin j'ai
quelqu'un pour tous qui dit kavala pay
and jehn à presque 7 et qui ramassent
tout mamadou c'est l'ange gardien de la
maison
ah oui oui alors ils nous gardent bien
bien non vous êtes ici monsieur que vous
voyez vivre monsieur gainsbourg et jane
birkin
alors comment ça se passe se passe tout
simplement pour moi personnellement
d'être césaire travailler avec et c'est
un grand privilège car j'ai trouvé
quelque chose tout à fait contraire que
j'entendais dans les journaux que des
fois que j'entendais dans la rue par des
gens qu'ils étaient méchants work qu'il
est tout à fait le contraire
peut-être qu'il a à regarder - le point
jour que même s'il représentait saison
je croyais j'ai eu peur parce que il
avait un regard et comme toujours il a
un regard dur et comme maire comme s'ils
souffraient quelque chose d'un
romantisme du moyen âge mais nous l
perkin ben elle aussi elle est très
douce affectueuse c'est que m surtout
touché c'est elle c'est l'affection
qu'elle témoigne auprès de sa mère la
mère de michel goulet aussi bien que
coûte ses parents elle est ce que vous
serez souvent les gens ou oui pas mal
pas mal mais un peu moins qu'attendu
ma fille a dû des invités plus souvent
tout mois ou plus vous devrez serge
havet
beaucoup plus souvent que ça alors elle
les a dans sa chambre à l essai j'avais
une guignols pour son anniversaire la
pâte en sachant ce était gay
[Musique]